hello this is some sub a channel about
how to survive
in the online jungle my name is bradley
and today
i'm going to tell you about how love for
rapping and instagram
destroyed a well-known group of cyber
criminals who helped hackers from all
over the world to launder money that was
stolen from ordinary people
now we're going to delve into some
fraudulent schemes that are described in
fbi documents
really cool stuff
so i'm going to introduce you to a guy
called maxim and
he's the lead character in the story now
he was actually born in yama peninsula
in siberia
where winter not only lasts for eight
months but in summer the average
temperature is only about
plus six now understandably max had
dreamed of miami money and a rap career
so max decides to focus on his hip hop
career and took on the name
plin official shortly thereafter this is
where it gets quite interesting
so on january the 19th of 2020 plym
officials getting ready to release a new
track
and actually flew to hang out in miami
at customs he declared 20 000
as being earned from bitcoin investments
and renting out real estate in russia
this is nothing special but the customs
officers checked max's photos on
instagram
and found kind of suspicious so while he
was hanging out in miami
don't feed him baby cheers
law enforcement officers started an
investigation
so while this was all going on the fbi
special agent samantha shelnick
got the permission from the court to
access maxim boyco's icloud
the investigation team discovered the
max team loved to take photos with
banknotes right but some of them he kept
as souvenirs and didn't actually post
anywhere
the us district court for the western
district of pennsylvania published the
testimony
of special agent sharnik and
subsequently the arrest warrant for the
rapper
according to fbi agents since 2015
boycott been helping criminals to cash
out
and launder money now this let him live
his fancy lifestyle as a rapper cheers
notably he cooperated with a hacker's
laundry named quas
group now according to europol quas
members are immigrants from places like
latvia georgia bulgaria romania and
belgium
so they opened and maintained hundreds
of corporate and personal bank accounts
worldwide
so they did this to launder money
basically from the cyber communities who
stole it in the first place from
accounts around the world using malware
now what's quite interesting is quizzes
hierarchy can actually
reveal the inner structure of many
different money laundering groups
so let's analyze it in more detail
the first thing we need to look at are
the leaders these guys develop
strategies for opening bank accounts all
around the world
they advertise cash out services on
cyber criminal internet forums and
coordinate the laundering process of
stolen funds from cyber criminals and
mid-level managers so this brings me on
to the second
rung which are mid-level managers these
guys receive direction from the
organization's leaders but they're
responsible for recruiting
money careers often known as money mules
to open bank accounts around the world
right they also arrange the travel for
money mules
it's also worth mentioning that maxine
boyco was also one of these mid-level
managers
right let's talk about the final run of
this ladder which are money mules
now these guys at times use eliases and
false identification documents
but other times they're actually using
their real identities now
they do this to register shell companies
and open personal and corporate bank
accounts
on behalf of institutions such as quiet
so what is a shell
company well a shell company is a sort
of corporate entity that's created
solely for the purpose of
opening bank accounts it doesn't really
have any business function
outside of being the named owner of
these bank accounts quiz group
cybercriminal clientele typically had
access to groups of malware infected
computers
these are also known as botnets you
might have heard of that now once a
computer is infected with the malware
the cyber criminals can then capture the
victim's online banking credentials
the cyber criminals then use those
victims credentials to log into the
victim's bank account and initiate
fraudulent wire transfers into accounts
that are controlled by the subject
in the u.s these attacks were usually
targeted at small companies and
organizations
such as a synagogue in brooklyn for
example
[Music]
who are the clients that are using these
guys well
for example there's a group of hackers
called the jabba zeus crew
now these guys use custom versions of
the zeus trojan to steal
tens if not hundreds of millions of
dollars from hacked small businesses
across the united states now this gang
works directly with the author of the
zeus trojan
his name was evgeny aka slavik bogachev
he's a russian man with a three million
dollar bounty on his head from the fbi
the cyber criminal organization that
bogashev allegedly ran was responsible
for the theft of more than 100 million
dollars from banks and businesses
worldwide among cuis's other cyber
criminal clientele were several
nefarious malware organizations
including gosnim drydex and triphop it's
important to note that these forums
provided virtual meeting places where
vetted cybercriminals sought out and
offered specialized technical skills
services and products
needed to engage in a variety of cyber
criminal activities
so quas is in this environment and it
advertises its cash out and money
laundering services on exclusive
underground mainly russian speaking
online cyber criminal forums
these forums include things like mazda
and verified right
so in order to facilitate the sale and
receipt of these services
the underground forums rented out space
to individuals or
groups that want to draw attention to
their particular illegal
service but it's important to note that
these advertisements on the darknet
could cost as much as 10
thousand dollars a year in one post quiz
actually advertise themselves as a
global complicit bank drop
service now from this advertisement we
can see that there's an availability of
bank accounts in numerous countries
throughout the world with these drops
or money mules who are complicit in and
knowledgeable of the criminal scheme
so now let's take a look at how
acquisition service generally operated
well firstly the cyber criminals with
this unauthorized access to the victim's
bank account
they'd look for a recipient bank to
which the cyber company could send the
victim stolen funds
secondly kwas provided the cyber
criminal with the details of the
specific bank account designated to
receive the stolen funds
then the cyber criminal initiates an
electronic funds transfer
from the victim's bank account to the
recipient account
and then if all goes to plan quas
receives the stolen funds in the
recipient bank account
now quas withdraws the funds and
transfers the funds to an illicit
tumbling service
this is where the funds are usually
converted into cryptocurrency for
instance
now finally quiz returns the stolen
funds to the cyber criminal
minus their fee obviously which was
typically between
40 and 50 of the total amount of stolen
[Music]
funds
[Music]
so the following table lists examples of
stolen funds from u.s victims that were
sent to choirs beneficiary bank accounts
as you can see most of the attacks
failed banks luckily noticed suspicious
activity in time and
managed to slow down or stop the
transactions altogether
i mean look here they tried to transfer
49 000 to portugal
failed 84 900 to spain
also failed but once it actually
partially worked they managed to steal
sixty four thousand and eighty two
dollars out of a planned one hundred and
twenty one thousand
three hundred and sixty dollars
sometimes they stole everything
as in this case uh or that one the fbi
doesn't disclose
the victims it only indicates the
company's type of activity
and when we look at the dates you might
notice that every month
these cyber commerce are performing
several attacks the quiet group
and its members managed to open and
maintain hundreds of bank accounts of
finance institutions
around the world including places like
united kingdom portugal spain
germany the netherlands and so on the
fbi eventually got a court order
together to
assess the group's cloud storage see
what was there
now they actually got hold of the google
drive for one of the participants
now this contained three folders saved
as bg
es and pt now
these files all contain the information
that was related to quasi's controlled
shell companies and bank accounts that
were located in
you guessed it bulgaria spain and
portugal so
let's actually take a look at one of
these folders let's open pt which stands
for portugal
this folder contains more than 30
subfolders each designated by the name
of a different portuguese shell company
portuguese authorities confirmed that
these shell companies
listed in the pt folder were actually
registered in portugal
and that these companies actually
conducted no legitimate business
whatsoever
so to further this conspiracy quiz
members would actually transfer
funds received from the cyber criminals
to tumbling services
where the funds were converted to
cryptocurrency through a series of
transactions that were designed to
obscure the original source of the funds
okay but what is a tumbling service well
bitcoin tumbling or mixing is the
process of using a third-party service
to break the connection between a
bitcoin address
sending coins and the address that they
are sent to
now this is a method of securing your
privacy by mixing your bitcoin with
other people's coins or new coins since
the bitcoin blockchain is a public
ledger that records every transaction
mixing coins is pretty critical for
anyone who doesn't want the entire world
to know
where they're sending or storing their
bitcoin more importantly
from where they receive it so that's why
quas chose this method
to launder money and cover up tracks so
in the end how were these guys caught
well catching the criminals was
surprisingly simple they were caught
having made a lot of
quite ridiculous mistakes either because
of stupidity
or just purely out of laziness so the
investigation really boiled down to
studying their social media accounts
linking phone numbers and emails
and studying screenshots that had been
made by the criminals
this all greatly facilitated the work of
the fbi
let's actually take a look at an example
of officer work now
everyone knows that icloud automatically
saves photos from whatsapp
this really helped the investigation
while whatsapp chats are traditionally
encrypted
media sent between phones such as videos
pictures documents and so on
they're not encrypted and therefore was
stored in the cloud account now this is
where it gets really interesting because
several
folders contained screenshots of java
chats now the images on this computer
showed confirmations of bitcoin
transactions and
similar information therefore it's a
probable cause to believe that
computer max belongs to maxine boyco
and that boyco is using his laptop in
the furtherance of money laundering
activities
well in october of 2020 there was a
large-scale special operation that took
place
with law enforcement officers from 17
countries
now this ultimately resulted in the
attention of 20 people that was
suspected of cooperating with this
quas criminal group now all of them are
now facing long-term prison sentences
law enforcement officers conducted more
than 40 searches in total in places such
as
latvia bulgaria great britain spain and
italy
what's more at that time criminal
investigations had already been
initiated in the united states and
portugal
as for maxim boyco well he was detained
in the united states in march of 2020
he pled not guilty thereby refusing the
plea deal
and this is actually a real case i mean
can you believe that
well anyway that's it for today so be
safe and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you